and Vic taper he covers the Raiders for
the athletic and joins us on the program
how much drama do we have
when is today going to be like after
last night's hard knocks Vic should be
good I think that sentimental Brown
shows up you got the Rams in town you
got the whole McVeigh Gruden thing going
on so a lot of energy on the field what
stood out to you last night on Hard
Knocks I thought I thought it was
obviously a vacation ever good
entertaining but I was rolled over slow
showing me really a big moments but I
thought John Holmes came off okay but
he's definitely show his person a huge
personality as we saw for a rookie but I
was too much for my taste I mean I mean
I really pay off and everybody came and
was a good little montage about it
change lockers pretty fast but there was
no big enough finale exam being cut that
was kind of a big buildup not much
repair all right but then you know I'm
not quite sure what to make of this team
and I try not to go I'm gonna base my
opinion on how they're gonna be this
year by watching them in training camp
but I can't help but look at this and go
it felt like they went out of their way
to pop me a pump up Derek Carr and
everybody a great throw great throw and
you know the whole thing about does the
oil up his arms when he goes out of them
like it's a little strange I think this
their success or failure it comes down
to maybe Derek Carr and his personality
and ability to you know be a franchise
quarterback is that asking too much
that's a good point I think there
definitely is a privity for Derek they
got all these weapons and tools this
year at about in here made sure Brown
the highest-paid offensive lineman in
the league the Antonio Brown and Tyrone
Williams so Josh Jacobs first-round pick
so definitely there's no excuses for
directors you have to have a big year
there may actually build for a new
quarterback next year what kind of
questions do you have for Gruden this
year usual questions about the offenses
you know yeah well actually and so too
much I think that was because of the
injuries the line and the you know they
trade away
Cooper is really in max the roster was
in kind of shambles by the way so this
he has gotten the guys he supposedly
wants he's got some characters like you
know a perfect incognito so let's just
see what does
he said last year was necessary so let's
see if that was true I was surprised
they didn't address Antonio Browns feet
why didn't they address it I'm sure I
would like to I'm sure they didn't know
where thank you everyone asking the same
questions but he was just it's a bizarre
week he takes near our air balloon ride
in and doesn't practice you can't fly as
in but there's not practice and now all
we hear about you know as it sounds I
was suddenly post a picture of his feet
which was not not great viewing for the
public but um and he's Encinitas people
have been kinda quiet today has been
quietly last Gruden everyday and nothing
so I think it's just kind of a
wait-and-see thing but I'll say this you
saw last night when I show like just a
brief time this twenty minutes he was
out here on Tuesday I ran some routes of
passions the cornerbacks he gave him you
know I can handle it more so I think
even with the bad feet he still you know
a playmaker so I think I took it fine I
think when his feet finally heal up he
should be the guy he always has been
okay but Antonio Brown who loves to
share everything with you is not sharing
how he did this to his feet Jon Gruden
who loves to talk and should be asking
Antonio Brown how did you do that he's
not saying anything and then Drew
Rosenhaus his agent who always loves to
talk he's not saying anything
why a boy yeah that's right around with
dark I'm social media like two or three
days where it's unheard of so I just
think we'll see if he's hired today I
think at some point you have to be I
think the team has been politely
concerned maybe get over frustrated by
Thank You business sharp in fact it's
pretty soon it might turn the corner and
become more of a a bigger issue if I
said that you could either take seven
wins or three wins you had to pick
between the two for the Raiders this
year
well I think I mean based on what they
did in the offseason I don't have to go
Savin I think the whole like slowly
rebuilding plan without wonder when they
sign there in brown it gave and totally
about a big pay raise I think seven at
the minimum I think you even eight or
probably eighty get to be a good season
so I think um they spent too much money
making moves for them now to look at the
whole building process and the worth of
a well three win season to remember
traffic I think look out that way big
thank you for your time and we
appreciate you taking some minutes here
to talk about what's going on with this
I'm sure that we'll check in with you
again during the season I know Vic taper
he writes for the athletic he covers the
Raiders for more Dan Patrick show tune
in the audience channel 239 on DirecTV
streamed for free on BR live or download
the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]